is a Broken Man
amid the chaos of one of the few
functioning airports here
having made the journey from South Wales
he is desperately trying to find a way
to reach the Mountain Village he grew up
in I mean it's completely collapsed this
is what is left of his brother Ali's
house Ali is dead his wife seriously
injured and two of his children are
missing in the rubble
we decide to take him or at least to get
as close as we can
halfway there he gets a call from his
surviving niece to say no one is coming
to help them Ahmed cannot bear it
once we're up in the mountains it is not
an easy Journey
we finally reached the village the
damage the reality of it all
[Music]
reunited with his sister fatter the
uncontrollable grief
also waiting for him his surviving niece
sidca
is her sisters ashraghul and Zara that
they are looking for now
it is heartbreaking
tells me it was a house full of joy and
love and now his family is destroyed so
Ahmed just tell me when you see this
what goes through your mind unbelievable
I never see this I am very sharp
I never see this happen before my left
never
he says the locals want to know where
the government help is the truth is the
government is overwhelmed
what would your message I said where are
you
we need the people accommodation with
everybody's freezing they've been only
locals people they count neighbors or
friends they will try Apple where is the
government
in these remote snowy Villages they will
have a long wait
I'm very sorry for your loss yeah
unbelievable
one man facing the enormity of it all in
this country of countless tragedies